la guerre interminable se poursuit entre
l'iran et l'irak l'aviation irakienne
bombarde à nouveau depuis hier la région
de bassorah
mais cette guerre dont on a déjà vu les
sévices sur les corps attaque aussi les
esprits
de part et d'autre les prisonniers qui
s'entassent dans les camps et dont
beaucoup sont des enfants les
prisonniers sont soumis à une offensive
psychologique que l'on constatait côté
irakien
philippe rochot et à l'ins sous les
portraits du président saddam hussein
six enfants combattants iraniens à
capturer sur le front ont été présentées
ou plutôt exhibé devant la presse car
les conditions dans lesquelles s'est
déroulée cette rencontre était
humiliante pour ses enfants de 12 à 14
ans encerclé par les flashs des
photographes et les objectifs des
caméras
ils avaient été capturés sur le front à
l'est de basra quelques jours auparavant
ils portaient encore leurs tenues de
combat font leur avait lavé et il
passait ainsi de la guerre à
l'atmosphère feutrée d'une salle de
conférence ont-ils eu de la chance
d'avoir la vie sauve
ils n'en sont pas convaincus l'ayatollah
khomeini refuse de récupérer ses fils de
l'iran car ils auraient dû dit il mourir
au combat
il est révoltant qu'un pays envoie ses
enfants se faire tuer mais il est aussi
choquant de voir son adversaire l'irak
les utiliser pour servir sa cause
nous ne pourrons avoir le contact avec
ses enfants que par l'intermédiaire de
cet homme qui filtre les questions mais
les réponses ont été préparés à l'avance
notamment quand on demande aux enfants
comment ils ont été engagés dans cette
guerre c'est à cause d'une grande
propagande dans le pays pas répondre ce
garçon de 14 ans on m'a obligé à
combattre on nous a dit allez vous
battre pour l'islam
mais parfois c'est la bavure
ils répondent par exemple qu'ils ont
quitté l'école pour aider leur père
alors que les autorités irakiennes
veulent leur faire dire que les écoles
ont été fermées afin d'envoyer les
enfants sur le front l'interprète
officielle va même démentir les propos
de ce garçon alors que peut-on croire
dans les réponses de ses enfants
humiliés la gêne est évidente chez tous
les journalistes qui participent à cette
conférence de presse et une certaine on
apparaît dans les comportements
la réalité c'est que ces enfants qu'on
nous présente comme les victimes de la
propagande de khomeiny reste convaincu
du bienfait de leur cause
une journaliste iranienne de
l'opposition autorisés à séjourner à
bagdad a pu s'entretenir avec eux
écoutez d'abord en tant que journaliste
y étaient scandalisés par cette
conférence de presse je crois que je
n'étais pas la seule et seconde doit en
tant qu'iranien je vous je voulais avoir
un contact direct avec avec ses enfants
donc j'ai demandé aux responsables
irakiens
autant avec eux je n'ai pas eu de
problème ils me l'ont à meulan accorder
autant avec les enfants j'ai un problème
parce qu'ils ont refusé au début de me
parler ils m'ont demandé de respecter la
tenue islamique donc j'ai porté le
tchador avant de pouvoir leur parler
alors on nous a présenté ses enfants
comme des victimes de la propagande mais
d'après vous est ce que le désir de ses
enfants d'aller à la guerre est sincère
oui je pense que le désir est sincère
certainement il ya une grande part de
propagande qui joue donc on peut dire
qu'ils ont été victimes
mais eux mêmes ne sens pas victime eux
voulaient venir vraiment sur le front
venez venir défendre la patrie et
défendre l'islam cette rencontre avec
les enfants de la guerre ne nous aura
pas permis d'expliquer les vraies
raisons qui poussent ces garçons de 14
ans à se battre en première ligne mais
entre l'iran qui les envoie à la mort et
l'irak qui les utilisent dans de telles
conférences de presse ils sont les
victimes de plus d'une atteinte aux
droits de l'homme